fit régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france régis bonsoir cette nouvelle
rencontre entre washington et les
talibans avec évidemment cet enjeu de
crise humanitaire mais dans le fond
régis est ce que les américains ont une
marge de manoeuvre est levé sur ce
dossier parce que soit on laisse mourir
une population de 2 fin soit de toute
manière on perd d'une certaine manière
la face quelle marge de manoeuvre et
quels choix pour washington
il ya plusieurs aspects dans la dans
l'attitude américaine aujourd'hui la la
les etats-unis ont voulu aux commandes
immédiatement après leur leur départ
calamiteux puisque faut bien le
qualifier ainsi date de l'afghanistan
renouer avec les taliban et on a vu de
la part des talibans aussi qui certaines
marques je dirais pas de sympathie mais
en tout cas vis-à-vis des etats-unis il
ya eu immédiatement un discours au
moment où les talibans sont arrivés au
pouvoir enfin oublier que les talibans
et les etats unis se sont combattus
pendant 20 ans et bien comme quoi il
souhaitait renouer des relations et que
les états unis alors derrière tout ça
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se cache il se
cache une chose d'abord importante c'est
que les talibans savent qu'ils eux pour
gouverner l'afghanistan
il va falloir qu'ils aient une politique
économique et financière et pour le
moment ils ne peuvent pas le faire
puisque certain nombre d'avoirs ça vient
d'être précisée justement par votre
reporter le ont été ont été gelés à
l'étranger donc ce qui fait que le
gouvernement taliban aujourd'hui manque
d'argent ont ils à un certain nombre de
2 2 lui contrôler une partie du pays là
aussi il ya beaucoup de difficultés de
la part des taliban à faire face
notamment à des groupes plus extrémistes
comme
haïti six cores hassan quitte donc les
gones émanation de dèche sur place qui a
commis déjà plusieurs attentats dont qui
respect sécurité et surtout comme je le
disais cet aspect économique est hélas
des talibans savent qu'ils ont besoin du
reste du monde vous avez souligné l'aide
qu'apportent les russes la corée du sud
également a décidé eux de fournir de
l'aide aux commence à l'afghanistan
l'inde aussi donc il ya un certain
nombre de pays qui ont accepté cela mais
il va falloir plus de choses puisque
pour ses grands amis en habitant risque
d'un risque de famine avec l'univers
potentiellement très dur qui va se
dérouler en afghanistan et vient pour
éviter la catastrophe humanitaire il va
falloir autre chose donc à la communauté
internationale à une manière de faire
pression sur les talibans on par exemple
les forçant d'une scène est ce qu'ils
ont réussi partiellement à faire les
talibans ont exprimé leur volonté de
s'engager auprès de la communauté
internationale en faveur d'un accès
complet à l'éducation notamment des
femmes etc donc ça c'est des paroles et
dizy blement quand même suivi d'effet et
et l'idée pour la communauté
internationale justement c'est de
troquer un petit peu cette aide contre
eux un brevet de respectabilité de la
part des talibans et la promesse qui ne
se livre pas à des exactions ouaki ne
durcissent pas leurs régimes comme il
l'avait fait quand ils étaient au
pouvoir entre 1996 et 2001 est ce que la
communauté internationale etats-unis en
tête peuvent-ils faire confiance aux
talibans qui vont nécessairement vouloir
comme vous dites offrir voilà une
crédibilité et faire preuve de bonne
intention mais comment obtenir des
garanties pour un avenir plus lointain
alors rien n'est certain pour pour
l'instant évidemment on ne connaît pas
et c'est là où la difficulté c'est de
savoir qui gouverne réellement au sein
des talibans qui est ce que c'est la
ligne dure incarnée par haqqani c'est à
dire les militaires ou est ce que c'est
la ligne il tirait plus
négociatrice incarné par le mollah
baradar qui était le négociateur
principal des talibans à tort pendant
toute la période avant le retour des
talibans au pouvoir donc il ya voilà il
ya déjà plusieurs plans il ya plusieurs
il ya eu des affrontements même entre
eux mais jusqu'à présent est la
difficulté va être de savoir si les
talibans vont pouvoir se contenter
aujourd'hui de ce qu'ils font c'est à
dire à d'administrer l'afghanistan sans
faire de coup d'éclat spectaculaires
montrant des marques d'extrémisme comme
ils ont pu le faire par le passé et et
lave pour le moment on sait qu'il ya eu
des exactions mais elles n'ont pas été
massive et non pas été la situation et
reste critique le régime est bien en
place la llo l'opposition a été d'une
certaine façon contenu il n'y a plus de
manifestations de femmes comme on avait
comme on l'a vu au début mais il n'y a
pas eu d' exactions et il n'y a pas eu
enfin il ya eu des exactions mais elles
ont été limités on dira voilà parce que
les talibans savent très bien qu'ils
jouent une carte comment fragiles qu'ils
doivent contrôler le pays il ne le
contrôle pas complètement gelé déjà dit
est également il en commet un problème
de montrer au reste du monde qu'ils
peuvent administrer et qu'ils sont des
interlocuteurs légitimes
ça c'est une chose est de ce point de
vue là ils se tiennent jusqu'à présent
et voilà et mais tout ça est ce que dans
le dans le dans le fond les talibans
l'intention de poursuivre dans cette
voie là toute la question n'est toujours
pas soldé ou est-ce que l'afghanistan va
redevenir un état paria comme il l'avait
été lors du procès la précédente
présence d'état des talibans au pouvoir
en afghanistan
merci beaucoup régis le sommier merci
pour votre éclairage ce soir